[Music]
give us an update on how you are I'm
doing I'm doing really good I'm in a
really good place the kids are happy
they're healthy tark and I are in a good
spot we have a lot of things that we're
working on cool things coming in the
future and we're just looking forward
like what thanks so right now we're
filming season 7 of flipper cloth which
we're hoping to continue shooting we
have our seminar company's success path
and I'm in the early stages of writing a
book that I'm really excited about
what's the future of the show what's
going on with it right now we're filming
season 7 and after that you know there's
a few things up in the air and some
offers were working on so you said
you're working on a book what's gonna be
in there Oh going through divorces it's
tough on anyone so I'm just kind of
writing about some of the experiences
that I've had and things that have
really helped me cope and just hoping
that I can help people going through
similar situations that's awesome and I
love hearing that can you give us maybe
one I know you don't wanna give it away
but one thing that you would say has
helped you go well you know putting the
kids first and you know breakfast and
the fact that we need to be happy
healthy wonderful parents how is filming
with tart going with what you guys have
been through it's going really good we
have an amazing crew they're like the
funnest funniest guys and and no target
and I have worked together for 10 years
and we're gonna continue to work
together and we're actually we're we're
getting along really really well right
now if you could pick one thing that is
the key to getting along really well but
what do you think is that key factor
that's helping you can do that it's just
like letting go of past resentment and
living in the future and remembering
that the kids are the priority and we
are gonna be in each other's lives for
forever have you guys made any decisions
when it comes to co-parenting how are
you moving forward with that honestly
we're just like very open communication
we both travel a lot so we're very
flexible with our schedules we both put
the kids first you know we just decided
to like really get on the same page and
make sure that we're both
just doing the best we can you look
amazing so I have to ask you like our
guy's asking you out now are you
thinking about dating at all because
you're beautiful I mean honestly a
relationship is the farthest thing from
my mind right now I just not even on my
radar
[Music]
you